aber anfang hieß es es geht darum die
infektionszahlen tageweise
unterzubringen dass ich für das raten zu
senken dann hieß es wir brauchen
infektionszahlen von 1500 damit dass
irgendein system das leisten kann am
anfang ist es meist um sein schädel ich
jetzt machen
das sind 9 plus ultra wir haben eine
corona app die nicht funktioniert also
das problem ist die vermittelbarkeit
wenn menschen das gefühl haben sie
müssen maßnahmen nachvollziehen die sie
selbst nicht in ihrem eigenen
wirkungsfeld für vernünftig halten
dann gibt es eben das problem dass
menschen sagen das mache ich das nicht
mehr ich wehre mich dagegen vor allem
die zeitspanne in der wir uns bewegen
ist ja extrem lang und wir leben in
einer phase des alarmismus auch wohl die
menschen jeden morgen aufwachen und
ihnen erklärt wird in brasilien sind
mehrere zehntausend menschen wieder
gestorben in den usa haben wir nur
infektionszahlen wie ein hot spots in
dithmarschen und das wird dann ein
landkreis der möglicherweise nicht mehr
wohl mensch nicht mehr ausreisen dürfen
das heißt dieser dauernde stress
situationen führt dann auch zu
merkwürdigen reaktionen von menschen
ich bin sicher bei den 20 oder 95.000
menschen die da waren waren eine menge
leute die für uns nicht verloren sind
sondern einfach verzweifelt sind weil
sie nicht mehr wissen warum diese
maßnahmen umgesetzt werden und was das
endgültige ziel der maßnahme ist